Sì mi chiamo ad in borghese oggi vi
racconto i miei limiti limiti che direi
che abbiamo tutti noi forse non facciamo
caso o forse al contrario Viviamo sempre
con questi e spero che il mio discorso
potrebbe darvi la forza di convivere con
questi limiti partiamo dall'inizio
partiamo sempre dal punto più importante
per me un sogno sono sono sempre stata
una ragazza che sognava il mio padre che
è molto simile a me mi diceva Devi
sempre puntare alla luna per arrivare
almeno alle stelle
così lui mi incoraggiava per raggiungere
tanto nella vita e da piccola sognava
tre cose viaggiare al più possibile per
tutto il mondo senza conoscere i confini
fare relazione internazionale senza
precisare perché poi dopo capirete
perché dico in questo modo e anche
essere giornalista
per caso dopo tanti anni della mia vita
mi ritrovo in Italia e in un paese che
mi affascinava che mi piaceva e ho colto
l'occasione perché credo che se c'è
un'occasione prendetela anche se
sbagliate meglio sbagliare meglio
rimpiangere però fatelo Questa è la
vostra esperienza che fa Voi diventare
ciò che siete oggi sono arrivata a
Milano e ho fatto uno stage insegnando
inglese una scuola media di periferia di
Milano sono stata accolta di una
famiglia che mi ha trasmesso tutto
questo amore per l'Italia per la lingua
italiana che io una ragazza da 19 anni
che non parlavo quasi niente
dell'italiano Mi sono innamorato perso
il cuore per questo paese e ho deciso di
fare tutto per trasferirmi in un paio di
mesi mi sono trasferita
Però posso dire che i primi anni come
qualsiasi persona che cambia paese da
solo senza le possibilità economiche che
ti possono garantire una vita tranquilla
senza avere un vero mestiere senza avere
un vero lavoro
vive un periodo molto duro e quello che
ho vissuto per i primi anni in Italia
che a volte chiamo il periodo delle
scoperte e il periodo della crisi
costante c'era tantissima gente che mi
diceva Ma come fai a vivere Tu
sopravvivi ma non vivi perché ci sono
tutti i limiti non parlino non riesce a
trovare lavoro non riesce a fare altro
però c'era sempre questo sogno se
Ricordate il film di Greg Gatsby
ricordate quel punto verde che guardava
sempre io ce l'avevo sempre lo guardavo
e sapevo dove io voglio essere e
qualsiasi situazione che forse potevo di
stabilizzarmi Cercavo proprio di non
pensarla come non ci fosse
le scoperte
perché tutto era nuovo
io sono dalla Russia sono di un
piccolissimo paese Russo industriale che
è stato fondato 80 anni fa non avevo
risorse della cultura della storia
quello che ha l'Italia mi affascinava
tutto e così ho capito che la
gastronomia il mondo della gastronomia è
quello che mi appassiona così ho
iniziato di fare corsi frequentare le
persone spendere tutto quello che potevo
sulla gastronomia se ristoranti corsi
alla formazione
c'era qualcosa che mi diceva e questo il
tuo percorso devi fare questo sono molto
grata a me stessa che io nonostante
tutto forse a volte anche per per un
male ma ascolto sempre me
ho seguito quella strada
ho fatto sempre questo che ho voluto ho
cercato di impegnarmi al massimo per
crescere nel mondo della gastronomia
Però un giorno quando già stavo molto
male perché ho perso il lavoro avevo i
debiti qualcosa non andava nella mia
vita e ogni giorno una cosa sempre come
una goccia se aggiungeva sempre un'altra
Ricevo il messaggio di un caporedattore
per chi scrivevo che lui non mi
permetteva più di scrivere della cucina
il ragionamento era quello non sei
italiana non avrai mai palato di uno
italiana e non riuscirai mai ad essere
credibile
immaginate come mi sentivo avevo 21 anni
pensavo che questo fine mondo e non
riuscirò più a proprio fare quello che
io voglio realizzarmi in questa vita
però come succede spesso dopo un
Breaking Point forse nasce qualcosa di
nuovo Forse però devo ammettere non ho
avuto mai un vero e proprio Breaking
Point della mia vita forse dite che sono
fortunata Forse però è anche la capacità
di non notare piccole cose che succedono
con voi non dare troppo importanza più
importanza date peggio è
oltrepassate qualsiasi cosa che ci sia
nella vostra vita come ci fosse una
quotidianità
stavo male in quel periodo perché io ho
perso l'occasione che mi sembrava
l'occasione della mia vita A quel punto
certo che adesso guardando indietro dico
ma questa era soltanto un episodio della
mia vita decisamente
però mi viene da dire
sempre dovete credere in voi sempre
dovete darvi del tempo perché il tempo
giusto arriva questo mi fa sorridere
Perché tre anni fa ero così ambiziosa
avevo tutta la fame per fare delle cose
per rincorrere i tempi per bruciare i
ponti bruciare tutte le tappe giusto per
farlo prima di tutti essere la più Young
essere nominata dappertutto arrivare
dappertutto e tutti i costi
ho capito che certe cose non puoi
anticipare devi sapere cosa vuoi fare
mettere tutto il tuo cuore questo ma
devi darti del tempo La società di oggi
soprattutto con noi giovani e io ho 26
anni oggi ci dice che dobbiamo essere
ambiziosi dobbiamo lavorare tanto è
proprio figo quando noi diciamo Ma io ho
lavorato fino alla mezzanotte No non è
figo perché vuol dire che il tuo lavoro
è più importante di te stesso
secondo me dobbiamo capire che l'unica
Scusate l'unico valore nella nostra vita
siamo noi assolutamente e non dobbiamo
anticipare i tempi Dobbiamo darci da
questo tempo nonostante che mi sentivo
male come tutti noi Io stavo cercando di
avere un confronto della mia famiglia
quanto potrebbe sembrare brutto non lo
avevo
Quando partivo avendo 19 anni come vi ho
detto Sono partita da sola
i miei genitori non sopportavano
quell'idea perché mi dicevano Ma non
trovi quello che fai in Italia non è una
professione non hai lingua non hai soldi
se succede qualcosa che fai Non pensavo
di queste cose
e quando ero già in quel periodo molto
brutto per me Io cercavo così tanto il
supporto dei miei genitori che non me lo
davano mi dicevano sempre con la frase
sai dove sei nata devi essere là perché
devi servire la il tuo destino è lì ogni
giorno che io sentivo quella frase mi
sentivo così male perché aspettavo che
le persone più vicine della mia vita
dovrebbero darmi il confronto dovrebbero
supportarmi e mi sentivo così male che
passano anni e quando torno indietro in
quel momento oggi a tutti voi che siete
genitori siete fratelli o diventate
genitori per favore supportate i vostri
figli credete incondizionalmente in
quello che voglio fare perché dobbiamo
davvero bisogno
sto piangendo perché è davvero
importante
è davvero importante
Grazie
come sempre i periodi Bui si cambiano
sempre con bianco e nero e arriva
qualcosa di più bello sono stata notata
proprio notata perché facevo il mio il
mio percorso come lo volevo io mi hanno
notato mi hanno proposto di scrivere o
finalmente scritto della cucina potevo
fare quello che io davvero volevo quello
che desideravo tutta la mia vita Non me
lo aspettavo che anche questo sogno
sarebbe il mio limite il limite di
giornalismo lo voglio parlare oggi
perché per me è molto importante perché
forse così Io lancio il messaggio per
tutti i giornalisti e tutti quelli che
vorrebbero avvicinare questo mondo
Sto cercando di abbandonare quest'ambito
per un semplice motivo non vorrei che il
giornalismo sia condizionato dalle
amicizie dalle sponsorizzazioni e delle
cose commerciali così vi dico
per un'altra occasione di conoscere una
persona giusta nel tempo giusto sia
creato il mio lavoro di oggi Sono
consulente mi piace chiamarmi agente
perché io lavoro con i cuochi stellati
lavoro con i bartender e lavoro con
l'hotel più belli e più grandi del mondo
il mio lavoro è farli emergere aiutare
loro a raggiungere i loro obiettivi
questo è stato successo Perché un'altra
persona che oggi è il mio cliente mi ha
detto io credo in te Tu ce la fai io
l'ho detto non ce l'ho mai fatta io ho
fatto due lavori di Scienze Politiche Sì
io parlo sei lingue Sì ho vissuto in
molti paesi che sono formate da solo
quello che oggi ma non ce l'ho mai fatta
è come faccio Non voglio prendere queste
responsabilità per me hai detto o del
tempo voglio investire questo tempo in
te
cosa voglio dire non limitatevi a
pensare che qualcuno non sappia che voi
potete farlo a volte le persone davvero
vedono
quello che siete vedono il vostro
potenziale e se voi riuscite ad essere
con la persona che dà la possibilità
agli altri che costruisce le nuove nuovi
ponti e le nuove possibilità per gli
altri soprattutto per i giovani fatelo
fatelo assolutamente
tornando al discorso di tempo
Io ero sempre fissata con con il
tempismo nella mia vita pensavo che
entro 25 anni devo raggiungere una cosa
entro 30 anni Voglio raggiungere
un'altra cosa sì non ce l'ho 30 anni
ancora ma c'era 25 e vi voglio dire
smettete di pensarla smettete ognuno ha
il tempismo suo
nessuno potrebbe dirti che tu lo devi
fare entro 30 anni entro 25 Non lo
sappiamo datevi il vostro tempo
Ho sempre saputo quello che voglio Però
ad un certo ad un certo periodo della
mia vita ho capito che non sento più il
tempo se mi chiedete cosa ho fatto ieri
forse non lo ricordo non vivo né di
passato né di futuro non esiste il
futuro Per me
qualsiasi cosa che faccio oggi è che
oggi posso avere una giornata piena
delle soddisfazioni e almeno una cosa
dovrebbe essere bella che la ricordo e
sono felice dico brava oggi hai fatto
una cosa bella
a dire ciò oggi
sto facendo il lavoro del mio sogno
perché qualcuno ha creduto in me
qualcuno mi ha dato la possibilità di
essere ciò che sono oggi
e vi dico una cosa noi giovani abbiamo
sempre il limite di essere giovani
perché ci dicono Sei troppo Yang per sei
troppo immaturo per non lo usiamo mai se
qualcuno pensa con il termine troppo è
già sbagliato non siamo mai troppo
perfetti non siamo mai troppo pronti non
siamo mai troppo maturi troppo giovani
siamo noi E se voi sentite che lo
meritate lo volete farlo fatelo
assolutamente non fermatevi a pensare
Non dovete essere condizionati da quello
che la società vuole da voi il pensiero
comune non dovrebbe essere attribuito a
tutti
per concludere vorrei riassumere quello
che ho detto
la mia famiglia è una famiglia media
però che avevo molte possibilità quando
stavo per lasciare la casa Avevo 17 anni
mi hanno detto che non mi danno la casa
non mi pagano gli studi o mi compro la
macchina non mi comprano i viaggi niente
quello che io vedevo per tutti altri
miei compagni di classe mi prendevano in
giro perché da piccolo Volevo vivere
all'estero fare la mia vita costruire il
mio business immaginavo me più o meno
come sono oggi più o meno
mi prendevano in giro dice no ce la fai
i tuoi genitori non ti danno nessuna
possibilità ma come fai sì avevo due
lavori Sì io studiavo quando mi sono
trasferito in Italia dovevo vivere con
una cifra impossibile ma oggi io voglio
dire un grande Grazie ai miei genitori
mi hanno messo nella situazione che io
avevo i punti di partenza Come si dice
in inglese The Thirteen Points Come
qualsiasi altra persona mi sono fatta da
sola i miei limiti si sono diventate le
possibilità perciò vorrei concludere con
la frase di Nico Romito che è una
persona molto cara per me
i miei limiti erano sempre i miei punti
di partenza
Grazie mille a tutti voi
[Applauso]